bang bang
what's up guys lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
planeta marinova who today looks like a
farmer
she has looking like a farmer
uh don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five get money get
paid
you they've got three products you can
buy and sell crypto you can deposit
crypto and earn
a us dollar loan or my favorite product
interest bearing account
you put in crypto or digital dollars and
they pay you 8.6
interest that's right 8.6 percent is
unheard of go check them out block five
dot com slash lunch money
or click on the link in the description
what's up
what's up are you are you over your
nonsense from yesterday
uh he almost didn't show up today
because of his performance yesterday but
we had a
nice little chat sorry i shaved my beard
made a little happy we're all good
are you gonna be nice to me no what's
going on with home buyers
[Laughter]
what's up with the home buyers home
buyer mortgage demand spikes to 11 year
high as rates hit another record low so
that means just
people are buying homes well of course
we are uh in this huge economic shock
and all the economic data is going down
people are losing their jobs
we're seeing all of the kind of social
unrest
uh stock markets exploding and what ends
up happening is
most people would think oh there's
economic shock there's a liquidity
crisis tone prices are going to drop
significantly and they wait on the
sidelines waiting to buy
well what ends up happening though is
central banks only have two tools at
their disposal they can move interest
rates or they can print money they're
doing both very aggressively
because rates have dropped so
aggressively down it's cheaper to borrow
capital when it's cheap to borrow
capital that means that it's a financial
incentive to go
and buy a home it's one of the biggest
reasons to borrow okay so what does this
mean for the future of the economy
well i i mean look yes it is related but
really the way i think about this
is uh it's more on the investment side
than the economy
right there's a lot of people who said
oh if an economic shock
happens real estate prices will fall and
i'll wait and i'll buy
but actually what we're seeing is the
opposite and it's because the federal
reserve acted so quickly to get
interest rates down to zero uh and also
print so much money
and so i've seen anecdotally there's
people tweeting about it a lot
saying hey look my friend just put a
house up for sale and in the first 72
hours there's five offers
uh and they sold it for higher than they
listed it for okay but do you think that
in the future as people lose as the
effects of so many people losing their
jobs start to hit
we'll see a decline no because i think
that
the interest rates are much more
important like the cost of capital is
way more important
because even if you lost your job but
you have enough for a down payment and
you can borrow it near zero
or very low cost two three percent then
all of a sudden you can go buy the home
and we know that based on the products
well that's part of what you got to
figure out but remember also there's
only
there's over 40 million people who have
filed for first-time unemployment
but the weekly uh kind of ongoing
unemployment is only about
20 million 20 22 million that's still a
huge number
right but unemployment based on the
official numbers is between 10 and 15
and so there's a lot of people who kind
of lost their jobs got furloughed
whatever
they're either going back to work or
they will be shortly and so
even if that's a true number let's say
20 million there's 150 160 million
people in the workforce right
so federal reserve though is not going
to move rates up anytime soon
uh actually jerome powell you'll love
this quote in the last meeting he said
we're not well he he said a lot of
a lot of okay but he also said
uh we're not even thinking about
thinking about moving rates
right and so it's just like look home
buying's going to keep continuing
as long as capital is cheap you want to
buy a home
should we maybe how about you buy your
[ __ ] off
how about you buy a home and i buy a
home and we'll be next door neighbors
but then you don't have to deal with my
[ __ ]
i mean i could consider it all right
what's going on with hey.com
hey.com is no hey no
it is a new email service that is an app
that went on the apple app store now the
hey.com
executives are calling app they're
saying that apple's
acting like gangsters hey.com is built
by basecamp
base camp is a business that uh have two
very outspoken founders
uh dhh which is david hansen and
he's got his middle name is h as well so
he goes by dhh uh and then jason freed
they are very very very much
anti-venture capital
anti-big tech uh and they basically said
look we're gonna reimagine
email um they've been working on it
they've claimed for two years
uh they've got a bunch of people who
they've tested it with who speak really
highly
they got it in the app store and apple
is now saying wait a second this is a
paid product meaning you pay a
subscription i think it's 20 bucks a
month
uh but apple is not getting a cut
because the way they built it is
you go on a website and you buy it and
then you use it through the app it makes
sense like why what do you mean why
there's tons of people who do this
audible used to do this
netflix does this no i'm saying it makes
sense for them to not
give a cut to apple of course yeah well
okay so listen to this tweet so dhh
tweeted wow i'm literally stunned apple
just doubled down on their rejection of
hayes ability to provide
bug fixes and new features unless we
submit to their outrageous demand of 15
to 30 percent of our revenue
even worse we're told that unless we
comply they'll remove the app
wow well okay so why are they not
applying the same standard to netflix
then
that's part of the point is basically
what they did is they've always
had uh language in there they just
haven't enforced it and now all of a
sudden they're saying oh we're gonna
enforce it for new people
the old people are kind of like
grandfathered in uh but here's the end
of the day
apple is under investigation for
anti-trust uh
things on two separate continents like
this
is not going to end well when you
literally say to somebody
we are not going to let you do something
unless you
pay us or give us a percentage
you can do that if you're a private
company and you just say hey look if you
want to use our distribution that's fine
right but you got to pay us money that's
okay but when you start to selectively
choose who you're going to enforce on
who you're not and you somehow only
choose to enforce it on people
that you compete with big big problems
so
but is apple competing with hey service
oh because of gmail because they have an
email service
right it's part of the it's part of the
apple ecosystem
and then the other piece of this is
they've done this to a lot of people
there's tons of people who
they've done this too recently uh ben
thompson had a great thread that
basically said hey if this happened to
you like reach out and he was like dude
i was blown away by how many people
but nobody wants to talk about it
publicly because they're scared of
retribution from apple
but these guys are standing up to apple
you tell them
but the base camp guys have big enough
audience right and look
by the way don't get it confused there
is very little doubt in my mind that
they knew that this would happen
uh or or maybe they didn't know how bad
it would happen
but they knew that if they kind of did
what they were going to do there would
be controversy because apple would
respond in some way
and that would drive controversy and
attention for the launch
it is interesting though because uh we
finished watching the
second part of the garth brooks
documentary yesterday
and um there was one song about domestic
abuse that was quite graphic like the
music video when he was when the thunder
rose
oh that's what it was and it caused so
much controversy he was like i did
not expect that but because of that
controversy
he was able to sell more albums etc so
do you think that this is actually a net
positive for hey
streisand effect effect but to be fair
i had not heard of hey before this which
i should have because i send an email
newsletter
but like this controversy made me hear
about hey.com
yeah of course this is definitely a net
positive they're gonna be fine and i
think that they'll prevail
because apple actually has less power
than these guys do it's so much easier
to yell and of course all you have to do
is yell and scream enough and all
now all the negative press all of the
issues anti-trust like the decks
actually stacked against apple
when they go up against them yeah if i
was apple i just like kind of just
do whatever these guys want make it go
away because it's just not worth it
yeah ain't nothing like when the
gangster
gets a table turned what's going on epic
games
okay sorry i just wanted to dance there
for a little bit was that dancing
yeah that's farmer dancing yeah that was
some weird [ __ ] okay go ahead what's
going on with the epic games
okay so you know epic games they make
fortnite did you just hit me with farmer
dancing
okay [ __ ] [ __ ] um sorry i lost my train
of thoughts all right epic games have
you heard of epic games they make
fortnite yes they're
uh they're out of kerry north carolina
where i grew up yes oh my god that's so
crazy
did you know that uh yes that's the
largest it's a multi-billion dollar
company
based in my hometown yeah north carolina
is such a random place to be based
not really okay i was based there
[Laughter]
so not so random are you a multi-billion
dollar company
uh no i wish 17 billion dollars that's
what they're raising money at 750
million dollar round you just took my
part
they make fortnite they're by far the
most popular
game developer in the world to put that
in perspective
them like all of major league soccer is
7.5 billion
yeah but an epic game is 17. first of
all soccer is not as popular in the
united states as other places
and two and two and two okay
major league soccer is like a poor man's
wannabe epl fact let's
watch if you if you agree let me know in
the comments epl's european uh
soccer league i don't think that's what
it's called um
but the national hockey league is only
21 billion
and here is fortnite 17 billion how's
that possible
yeah i mean because they have way more
fan like just think of
uh how big the business is fortnite is
literally there's not a kid
on the planet who's not playing fortnite
also did you know that epic games
also owns house party that app
yeah they bought it okay but did you
know that actually the
the most important thing that they have
is called i think it's called unreal
engine or real engine
uh which is their like uh platform that
they use to build a lot of this stuff
and they also opened it up to other
people
fascinating company uh there's this guy
matthew ball who used to run
amazon studios i think or strategy at
amazon studios
and he writes a lot about uh epic and
fortnite and how he thinks that video
games are the new media companies
and you see it with things like where
they have travis scott come in and do a
concert
and literally millions of people show up
to the concert how do you read so much
on the internet
because i read the internet yeah but and
i know things
is that your way of telling me i'm
intelligent no it's my way of telling
you
that instead of talking to me you're
spending a whole lot of time reading
stuff
well maybe if you were teaching me
things i would be spending more time
talking to you oh my god what's going on
with boston dynamics
what's going on with boston dynamics
boston okay so i love
boston dynamics do you know why hit us
because
don't do that come on okay he's taking
over my computer it's annoying
um so boston dynamics has that
robotic dog thing called spot and
it can do anything like it's helped
doctors
apparently i mean it's done a lot of
things wait what what did it do with
doctors
it's helped them hold on one second guys
so now
instead of so boston dynamics was kind
of like out of
boston and you couldn't buy this dog but
now
you can buy spot the robot dog for
five 74 dollars do you wanna make an
investment
it's not an investment it's appreciating
assets like when you drive a car off the
lot the robot's gonna be worthless no
the second you get it
yeah i'm positive uh so help you like it
helps doctors
it doesn't help doctors first of all
second of all no other robots might help
doctors but this dog does not
this is the dog that if you guys
remember the video top spot recently
went to work in a boston
hospital helping screen patients for
disease
okay they mounted a tablet on its face
so the robot didn't help the doctors the
robot no the robot was basically just
a like a version of an autonomous
vehicle in the hospital it wasn't
helping the doctors do it and second
it was fetching them yeah exactly it's a
job that no human wants to do and the
whole
point of boston dynamics is to help them
do the dull
dirty and dangerous work bringing a
tablet to the doctor
is 3ds in robotics bringing a tablet to
the doctor
literally there are thousands of nurses
and support staff at hospitals that do
that every day they don't want to do it
they could be doing something much more
important
it's not dull dirty or dangerous they
just glued a tablet to
the dog's face and now i've been in a
hospital before where they have the
autonomous machine thing right it was
like moving around it was bringing
uh it was all the prescription pills
they would lock it in and then it would
go to the hospital
uh room that was supposed to go to it
was the most annoying thing because it
like goes and anytime it comes anywhere
near a person it stops to start making
noise
so like you can't even walk down the
hallway at the same time then it's like
bumping into things
like come on just give me the thing this
dog is incredibly intelligent have you
seen
one robot dog open the door for its
other robot dog friend
yes i have seen that and i've also seen
them use the dogs to police in parks for
social discipline oh yeah that's right
so
if you want to buy spot one of the new
robot dogs you got 75
000 knock yourself out you can i guess
glue a tablet to its face
and have it walk around your house and
maybe like a moving tv or something who
knows
man all right what's going on with unhap
what is unhappy why is that a topic
are you happy i'm very happy good so
americans aren't
um people in the u.s are more unhappy
today than they've been
in nearly 50 years based on this massive
study
it finds that just 14 of american adults
say that they're very happy
which is down from 31 who said the same
in 2018.
i call [ __ ] why you don't trust any
studies so like of course you're gonna
call them well one
i don't i don't uh trust the studies two
we live in the most prosperous safe time
in human history okay but this year has
been
rough okay that's fine but that still
doesn't mean that people are not happy
right according to this survey people
claim they are not that's great who did
the survey
um just like this is my favorite part of
when her and i look at things on the
internet who did a survey university of
chicago like they are legit
no nork at the university of chicago
yeah so what's that
york is legit what's nork i don't know
all right well you find out what newark
at university of chicago
is the independent nonpartisan research
institution that helps
governments nonprofit national opinion
research center so it's opinion it's not
facts
where'd you see that uh that's what
newark stands for national opinion
research center it's corporate
headquarters
it's located in downtown chicago exactly
attracts
sentiment and opinion oh my god i'm not
gonna okay just accept that americans
are not happy
and let's move on by the way i actually
agree that americans are probably less
happy than they were last year simply
because of all the chaos
uh and the feeling of the protest the
social unrest covet all that kind of
stuff
but i just think that when they show
this is basically saying
that there's been a 50 reduction
in people who claim to be happy people
don't know so 50
yeah come on what survey would show that
big of a move
this survey my my issue is that a lot of
times people
themselves don't know how they feel or
what they want
right so when you ask like if you ask me
right now are you happy i'd say yes but
if you ask me yesterday after lunch
money if i was happy i'd say no because
i was gonna not be so kind to my friends
if you know what i mean
um i just don't agree that surveys when
they do this sentiment type stuff humans
are really bad
like if i just said that like if i ask
you right now i just said that
i know but how many hours did you sleep
last night eight
in five minutes that's what it said no
wait what do you mean
you you saw more than that no that's
what my watch says okay you slept more
than that
and so the whole thing is like that then
ask you uh how many times did you eat
yesterday
if i asked you how many um times did you
check your phone or whatever like humans
are really really bad
and it's the same thing if i said to you
how many days a week do you work out
fast an average person
they will actually say it's
scientifically proven that they will say
what they think they do but what they
think they do is derive
from exactly what i just said what they
want to be doing i know
a lot of times people are more
aspirational than realistic
that's a great way to sum it up that's
very concise
you way tell if you're being facetious
no it was that was great what's up with
vr vacations
that maybe vr vacations will make people
happier yeah well that's why i included
it so we are vacations
it's like it's like two great minds
thinking alike
no just one just one place fine um i
know that
one great mind is here that's why
paulina the farmer
um okay so vr vacations there's a lot of
lonely older people who used to travel a
lot
but for example they um they talk about
this one lady
who isn't used to staying at home um
and she and her husband lived on a boat
for eight years they sailed from canada
canada to panama panama is that how you
say it um
but her husband passed away last year
now she uses a walker
and she can't go long distances or get
on a plane so
virtual reality has been able to give
her a sense of like she's touring
a spanish city and things like that and
she really loves it and it's making
people less lonely
i was convinced for the longest time
that this would be a massive business
really
yeah i think a lot of people were yeah
but you know what i thought people would
want to do
what in hospitals oh yeah right
is like allow people to go see it uh
there was a company in la that was
trying to do something like this like uh
to see other places yeah like imagine if
you're a kid in a hospital and you can't
go anywhere like what's the best way to
pass the time is like let's bring you
somewhere else let's bring you to disney
world let's bring you to mount everest
let's bring you like where
did that take off i feel like well it
looks like it's starting to down i mean
there's a couple of reasons one is it's
really hard to get the uh content
so like uh a lot of people don't know
this but google maps if you go to
um street view right where like it shows
you the houses like
they've literally drawn they've driven a
car down that street that's how they
capture it
well if you go on google maps there's
certain places where you can go
underwater
you can go on mount everest like you can
do all this stuff but they literally
sent people there and so
uh it's a little bit of a sad story but
um there's a guy who is
uh friends with a lot of my friends uh
his name is
dan and he was one of the founders of i
think these are called like google
explorers or something and basically on
google they were employees of google and
on google's dime they would go do like
extreme things like go
deep water diving they would go you know
hike everest whatever
um and uh and they would carry these
massive
uh basically cameras on their back and
they would just like walk
and they would be taking 360 degree uh
videos
um dan unfortunately died uh
in a avalanche uh on everest
um and he was like the life of the party
he's just a fantastic guy
um but that's how they have to do it so
it's like super hard and very expensive
obviously to get the content
and then two is uh previously it was
really hard
uh if you're sitting there and uh it's
not perfectly done in terms of how it's
delivered
inside of the hardware like realistic
although it gives you a headache you can
get like feel
uh dizzy like all that kind of stuff and
then lastly and probably the most
important part is
uh it was really hard to get the
hardware so it was expensive all that
kind of stuff now things with like
oculus have drastically
reduced the the cost um but i think that
we're starting to get closer and closer
to
hardware being right software being
right and the collection of the data
being low cost enough to make it
possible
so i think you know this but one of the
things that makes me the saddest in life
is when i think about older people who
are in these nursing homes who are like
becoming increasingly isolated and
lonely
and i i hope that this is maybe a way
that they can be less lonely
yeah or they can just use facetime
calls people up yeah but you can't call
people at all hours in the day and
yeah you can there's somebody always
awake it's like five o'clock somewhere
somebody always awake somewhere um
so the the great grandmother that's 90
years old uh she loves him
so every time she's she's a woman she of
course she loves me
every time i facetime her even if he's
like on the phone she's like get him
got it gotta talk to him gotta say
something i'm like well he's on the
phone
now i come over and i drop for all you
bulgarians out there i hit her with two
sentences
tcm nogo cresiva and obichomte
which means you look gorgeous today and
i love you and she goes wild she's like
90 years old
i get scared i think she might have a
heart attack when i say it to her yeah
she's fine all right that's it for lunch
money today appreciate you guys watching
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get her lunch money
right
hey.com vr vacations robot dogs only
place on the internet where you get the
real content
and get real annoyed all at the same
time see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends